[Music]
Hollywood has lined up plenty of
high-profile horror projects in 2018 and
no surprise most of the best ones are
slated to hit theaters right around
Halloween from jungle predators too
freaky nuns the future looks very dark
indeed in the best possible way here are
all the horror movies that will blow you
away this Halloween season
Slender Man lovers of creepy internet
memes have a pretty good idea of what to
expect with this upcoming horror film
the Slender Man has stalked the web
since 2009 when a Photoshop contest
produced a picture of the tall thin
faceless stalker of hapless children the
forum poster who made the image even has
a writing credit on the film a
development he probably didn't expect
when he set out to freak people out with
his photoshop skills then that's what I
will say unless Slenderman commands me
to say something else
the film's plot involves teen girls
performing rituals related to the
Slender Man and stars Joey King and Jess
and Claire Sony and Screen Gems have
slated Slender Man for release on August
24 cadaver audiences may know Shay
Mitchell best from her role on TVs
Pretty Little Liars but this Halloween
season the Canadian actress is making
the jump to horror with cadaver Mitchell
stars as a Mork technician and disgraced
former cop with a drug problem whose
late night shifts at the morgue take a
turn for the sinister when she receives
a badly brutalized body veteran dutch
director Dieterich van Ryan makes his
Hollywood debut with this feature
although cadaver has wrapped principal
photography audiences will have to wait
until August 24th to get a look the
Little Stranger writer director Lenny
Abramson spent several years quietly
making a name for himself in his native
Ireland before making a huge splash with
the 2015 international production room
despite receiving only a limited release
in the u.s. room was nominated for a
slew of awards and snagged a Best
Actress Oscar for lead brie Larson for
his follow-up project Abramson has taken
on an adaptation of the well-received
2009 novel the little stranger by Sarah
waters a film which took about 10
seconds to get snapped up by Focus
Features for worldwide distribution
after going
the production in summer 2017 the
post-world War two ghosts story boasts a
strong cast which includes domhnall
gleeson Ruth Wilson and will Poulter the
little stranger is slated for release on
August 31st the nun the series that new
line is now officially calling the
conjuring universe is getting another
spinoff this Halloween season the
franchise scored yet another box-office
hit with Annabelle creation a pre
prequel exploring the origins of the
sinister doll from the conjuring pushing
the series worldwide box-office take up
over the 1 billion dollar mark hitting
those kinds of numbers can only ensure
plenty more films in the pipeline and
the first up is the nun which will add
some backstory to one ik on during twos
must terrifying characters American
horror stories taissa farmiga the
younger sister of Maine conjuring series
Star beer afar Myka has been cast in the
lead with Bonnie Aaron's reprising her
role as the demonic nun Ballack
creatively the spin-off appears to be in
good hands
Annabelle and Annabelle creation
screenwriter Gary dal Berman penned the
script and Corrin Hardy has been tapped
to direct party used practical effects
whenever possible on the shoot portions
of which took place on location in
Romania and Transylvania
he told Entertainment Weekly I always
want to say let's do everything as much
as we possibly can for real including in
camera stunts effects and then use the
CGI to be a beautiful original invisible
tool the nun will return to scare your
pants off on September 7th 2018
slaughterhouse of rules horror comedy is
notoriously difficult to pull off but if
any filmmakers have earned the benefit
of the doubt it's Simon Pegg and Nick
Frost their 2005 classic Shaun of the
Dead remains a sterling example of the
genre and slaughterhouse Rules promises
to deliver shocks and laughs in equal
measure
the first effort from the pair's new
stolen picture banner takes place in a
British boarding school that becomes a
bloody battleground when a mysterious
sinkhole appears at a nearby fracking
sites unleashing unspeakable horror with
Pegg and frost serving as producers the
film is certainly in good
writer-director Crispian Mills also
directed back in the 2012 horror comedy
a fantastic fear of everything the film
is backed by Sony Pictures which should
ensure a fairly wide release when it
hits theaters on September 7th the
predator attempts to reinvigorate the
predator franchise have not historically
fared well the alien versus Predator
mashup series failed to do justice to
either franchise and the 2010 sequel
predators garnered mixed reviews but the
forthcoming sequel the predator appears
to be in very good hands
Shane Black will direct from a script he
co-wrote with Fred Dekker the two
previously collaborated on 1987's the
monster squad featured in the cast are
keegan-michael key Olivia Munn and Jacob
Tremblay who is apparently really
getting into the role Jacob
we have to get down to your skull and if
all of this isn't enough to get fans
excited then maybe the words of 20th
Century Fox CEO Stacy Schneider will do
the trick she said we've got a predator
film coming out that is unexpected and
utterly fresh from the first page it
didn't read like a predator film the
predator sneaks into theaters on
September 14th the house with a clock in
its walls in this upcoming film a
ten-year-old boy moves in with an
eccentric uncle only to find his house
full of secret passageways and strange
goings-on it turns out that his uncle is
a warlock a witch lives next door and
the house is a conduit for weird black
magic rituals if told you is everything
well not everything the house with a
clock in its walls is an adaptation of
the 1973 gothic horror novel of the same
name and there's already some serious
talent on board notorious horror
filmmaker Eli Roth will direct a cast
that includes Jack Black and Cate
Blanchett with its strong fantasy horror
vibe this movie is bound to be a unique
addition to the 2018 Halloween season
find out when it premieres on September
21st Hellfest this upcoming horror movie
is set in a Halloween themed amusement
park where a psycho slasher decides to
have a little holiday fun of his own
Gregory Plotkin editor of happy deathday
and get out has taken over as director
and Amy Forsythe Rainn Edwards and Bex
taylor-klaus have joined the cast
expectations are high for this one with
former James Cameron partner and walking
dead producer Gale Anne Hurd also
involved CBS Films president Terry press
has been championing the film for years
believing it has the potential to start
a new purge like horror franchise you
can judge for yourself when Hellfest
debuts on September 28 2018 something in
the dark this tech based thriller has a
unique premise a blind woman has her
sight restored by a pair of high-tech I
glasses
unfortunately her vision may turn out to
be a little better than she bargained
for the glasses apparently let her see
ghosts and she can't tell the difference
between the ghouls and the living even
worse she begins to suspect that a
lurking entity she keeps glimpsing might
be coming for the film's website states
that it will contain no dialogue with
the goal of creating a more involving
and creepy experience which plays
exactly the same to any audience
regardless of what language they speak
in other words there is literally not a
single word spoken throughout the entire
film the first feature for visual
effects artist turned debuting writer
director Steven Aguilera something in
the dark will definitely be a unique
experience it's currently stated for
release on October 15th 2018 Halloween
remakes and reboots of classic horror
franchises haven't exactly been
cinematic gold in recent years with yet
another nightmare reboot struggling to
get off the ground and a planned second
Friday the 13th reimagining still up in
the air fans could be forgiven for not
getting too excited about the prospect
of a new Halloween but they should be
eastbound and down star Danny McBride
and producer David Gordon Green came
together to work on the concept for the
new film which they pitched directly to
original writer Co director John
Carpenter carpenters reaction posted to
his Facebook page was enough to get any
fans heart racing David and Danny both
came to my office recently with Jason
Blum and
their vision for the new movie and wow
they get it I think you're gonna dig he
also told CBS that the new movie would
essentially retcon everything after
Halloween - it's pretending the other
sequels didn't happen McBride echoed
that idea saying it's going to continue
the story of Michael Myers in a really
grounded way as for our mythology we're
focusing mainly on the first two movies
and what that sets up Jamie Lee Curtis
and Nick Castle the original Michael
Myers are reprising their roles from the
1978 film Miramax will release Halloween
on October 19th 2018 just in time for
the scariest night of the year
overlord from JJ Abrams bad robot
production company Overlord is a world
war ii set horror flick about a group of
American soldiers who make a horrifying
discovery and a nazi-occupied village
since this is a bad robot production
there's been a lot of speculation that
Overlord may be yet another stealth
entry in the Cloverfield universe a
theory which was apparently confirmed
how will it tie into the franchise we
can all find out when overlord debuts in
theaters on October 26 thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you love to
[Music]